hello everyone and welcome to Thermo
Fisher Scientific webinar series on
Sanger sequencing and fragment analysis
made easy corresponding with the launch
of applied Biosystems new seeks to do
genetic analyzer today we present the
third topic in a series enabling
neurological disease research via a DNA
fragment analysis on the seeks to do
genetic analyzer presented by dr. Gary
Latham senior vice president research
development at a surgeon I'm Suzy Valdez
and I'll be your moderator for this
educational webinar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and won't answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice you're
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon on the lower right if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation click on the support
button or use the Q&A button to let us
know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button at the bottom
left hand corner and follow the process
for obtaining your credits I now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Gary
Latham dr. Latham is a senior vice
president of R&D for a surgeon a
molecular diagnostics company focused on
genetic and oncology's Barry joined a
surgeon when it founded in 2006 and
currently oversees the company's
research assay development partnered rnd
and bioinformatics
team he guided the development of
athletics PCR technology for fragile X
syndrome and other DNA repeat disorders
and DNA and RNA based quantum X NGS
products for oncology applications gary
is an inventor on 12 issued US patents
has received over 13 million dollars in
research grants for the nih in cancer
prevention and Research Institute of
Texas and has authored over 40
peer-reviewed publications please join
me in welcoming dr. Garry Latham along
now presentation over to him all right
Susie thank you for the introduction
it's a real pleasure to be here and I'd
like to thank our partner at thermo
Fisher for the opportunity to present
within this webinar series I'd like to
talk about some novel technology that
we've developed an insurgent and how it
may be combined with the new seeks to do
genetic analyzer and I'd like to begin
by talking about three problems there
relate to challenging genetic analyses
and propose a potentially unifying
solution so problem number one how do
you reliably PCR amplify some of the
toughest stretches of the human genome
the advanced clinical research problem
number two how do you simply and easily
resolve these PCR products to generate
high-definition insights and problem
number three how can you operationalize
a straightforward workflow that can
interrogate these challenging low-side
to enable jammu team analysis and the
solution I believe is to pair a process
of PCR with a high performance platform
the right innovation with the right
instrument but before I get there I'd
like to first talk about some of these
really hard to amplify patches of the
human genome this dark DNA and how it is
emerging and has emerged and the
important regulatory elements in
expression and in many cases is bonafide
biomarkers of inherited disease with
implications that range from
neurological disorders to reproductive
health so with my disclosures in the
background let me begin by saying that
the known genome is not the whole genome
nor is it the whole story for markers of
genetic disease and although we're
nearly 15 years past the official close
of the human genome project we still
don't have a fully complete end-to-end
sequence of our genome and although
estimates vary we currently have about
five percent of our genome sequences
devised defied conventional sequencing
technology and has remained dark and
although we don't know the exact
sequence of this dark DNA you do know
that it's comprised of mostly repetitive
DNA but we have an opportunity now with
new technology to be able to shine a
light on this dark DNA and to understand
the specific nature of this sequence
because we have long read NGS it's now
available they can read through these
repeat elements and the flanking
segments to be able to contextualize
repeats and we have the purpose
bioinformatic analyses that can address
some of the special challenges of repeat
DNA to be able to define the sequence
and it's not a surprise that this
remaining recalcitrant dark DNA is
repetitive in nature because in fact
half of our genome is comprised of
repetitive DNA and can bucket that into
about three different categories there's
a large chunk that's Richard transposons
another component that's DNA transposon
and a third category that's STRs our
short tandem repeats and these are
motifs of one to six
so nucleotides that are scattered
throughout the genome and are very
abundant for example we know that there
are at least a million STR elements in
the genome and just looking at the real
estate that they occupy they consume
about ten times the landmass of the
genome compared to snips and even twice
that of our coding to know in addition
to being highly abundant they're also
highly plastic the permutation a per
generation mutation rate associated with
STRs is can be orders of magnitude
greater than snips and that means that
they can be highly variable in different
populations further because they can
occupy multiple length states they are
multi allele a so unlike snips which are
typically binary it's a C or it's a T
with a repeating element it can be
different lengths and thus can function
over a digital continuum of possible
states that may have an ability to fine
tune any functional impact they have and
when we speak of function we should also
think about their potential roles in
gene expression because 20% of genes
have at least one pure STR within about
one to two KB of transcriptional start
site so these repeating elements are
poised in the regulatory regions of
genes that suggests they can have an
important functional role in the cell
and they have links to disease so that's
the general lay of the land and
demographics of STRs why they may be
important to pay attention to but in
addition we also have specificity from
single gene studies that suggest how
they may modulate function in
particularly gene expression so for
example bi-directional transcription we
know can be influenced by repeats where
increases in the number of repeats can
alter
the level of sense or any sense
transcription and a good example of this
is SC a8 spinocerebellar ataxia type a
this is a disorder with a pathogenic
repeat expansion where interestingly the
sense transcript be translated into a
toxic poly cute protein where is the
antisense transcript which contains the
repeat can be a sync to bind the
splicing factor muscled wine and trigger
a larger-scale splicing defects within
the cell l in addition we have also
quite a bit of evidence of more direct
effects on RNA splicing as a way repeats
can affect expression for example it's
been known for years now that the TG
repeat in intron 8 and the CFTR gene
alters splicing at exon 9 which then
reveals itself in some cases in the
clinical phenotype of male infertility
with congenital viola and lateral
absence of events deferens and non
classic cm further epigenetic
modifications are well known with
pathogenic repeat expansions fragile X
treaty take taxi or two such examples
where one that repeat exceeds a certain
threshold then you see repressive
chromatin marks laid down and silencing
of the gene which is directly associated
with the consequence of the disorder and
in addition we also know that is repeats
get tangled with in the transcription
bubble they can also bind to the DNA
within that bubble and create our loops
that themselves can have an impact on
epigenetic modification and so in
general what we've seen in more and more
cases is that increases or decreases in
the number of repeats can affect a G
expression by increasing or decreasing
transcription and although that's very
clear from
and these individual gene studies now
we're beginning to look with the right
tools both informatica li am from
standpoint methodology and technology
Gino and why so that we can canvas the
genome we can look at these STRs and
understand that functional impact and
the terrific paper came out last year
from Melissa Jim reg and Nina early in
Nature Genetics that showed that they
could identify more than 2,000 est ours
whose lengths were linearly associated
with nearby gene expression and could
explain 10 to 15% of sis heritability
attributed to common snips and so
repeats may in fact be a way to help
understand that quote missing
heritability that's been associated with
some diseases so in addition it's useful
to think about the functional impact of
STRs in terms of how intolerant or not
they may be it a mutation now on one
hand I mentioned that STRs can be much
more plastic than snips by comparison
but that doesn't mean that they're
tolerant mutations at every locus which
then suggests function within their role
and there's no and this study which just
came out within the last one looked
specifically at whether STRs were
genetically constrained and the way this
study was conducted was to take data
from the gtex database and look across
different tissues and compare the impact
of STRs with the top 20% expressed genes
compared to the bottom 80% and asked the
question are the top expressed genes
more genetically constrained with
respect to STRs they differ from one
tissue to the next and what they found
was that they are constrained in almost
every tissue the level of genetic
constrained was highest in the most
highly expressed genes but what was
really fascinating about this study was
the genes that were most constrained
were abundant within the brain compared
to any other tissue and that's
tantalizing to think about giving that
many of the canonical repeat expansion
disorders are pathogenic in the brain
and brain related tissues so let's recap
we have repeats that are dark in
sequence but are increasingly
discoverable thanks to long reading
next-generation sequencing is a
discovery tool we have repeats that are
dark and function but are increasingly
knowable because our understanding of
the linkage between STRs gene expression
and also potential Association disease
and the coup de Gras is that we have
more than 30 known disorders that are
associated with repeat expansions and
these disorders represent an
overabundance of disorders of the brain
neurodevelopmental neurodegenerative and
neuromuscular and they can represent
expansions in introns or in exons like
the public you disorders or in 3 or 5
prime utrs I'd like to put a spotlight
on a handful of these today five of
these and talk specifically about how
we've developed PCR technology to be
able to consistently read through these
repeats whether they're 18 rich or
gc-rich
and how those products can be
interpreted on the right platform like a
genetic analyzer capillary
electrophoresis to generate definitive
results for clinical research and I'll
talk about four of these pathogenic
disorders one emerging risk marker and
Alzheimer's disease and these represent
three products that we've developed that
are on marketed from the surgeon and two
that are in development so let's start
with fragile X the fragile X is caused
by a CGG repeat expansion the bob prime
UTR and more modest s' repeat expansions
are known as pre mutations and those
have 55 and 200 repeats and they're
relatively common in a population about
one in 200 women about 1 in 400 men are
pre mutation carriers and because of
this incidence fragile x sits aside SMA
and cystic fibrosis and a handful of
others as a common target for carrier
screening but in addition carriers are
at risk for a couple of different
fragile x associated disorders one of
these is fax tasks or fragile X
Associated tremoring taxi a syndrome
this is an age onset neuringer native
disorder the symptom on G is often
confused with Parkinson's disease and
then in women facts point which is
fragile X associated premature ovarian
primary ovarian insufficiency and fax
boy affects about 20 to 25 percent of
premutation women and many others that
are carriers may have modeled of forms
of ovarian dysfunction so this is a very
significant disorder within
communication carriers more extreme
application or expansion of the CGG
region in fmr1 of beyond 200 repeats
there's known as a full mutation and
that's the cause of fragile X syndrome
which is the most common known genetic
cause of autism and a major nerd
developmental disorder it occurs in
about one in 5,000 boys and girls and
it's important then across the spectrum
to be able to have technology that can
accurately flag full mutation expansions
but then also accurately assign the size
of the CGG repeat within the pre
mutation or other ranges and this is
important for several reasons one you
need to be able to differentiate true
homozygosity and females from apparent
homozygosity in other words it's
advantageous to be able to have even
single CGG repeats Ellucian so that you
can tell the difference between a 29 and
30 versus a homozygous 29 29 or a 29
that's heterozygous with a bull mutation
that using conventional pcr technology
might drop out in addition because
categorical boundaries are defined by a
single repeat it's important to be able
to have accuracy for the CGG numbers so
you don't miss categorize a sample and
then finally in the case of pre mutation
women who are at risk in transmitting a
pre mutation allele that can expand to a
full mutation in the next generation
it's important that accurately size the
CGG repeat because even though plus or
minus two CGG difference in premutation
women can translate to a 20%
differential risk for expansion in the
next generation so you want to make sure
that you get that right the question is
how do we do that how do we deal with
the fact that this is a CGG repeat
expansion by definition it's a hundred
percent GC how do we deal with the fact
that we need to identify more than 200
repeats of these and some of these
repeats can be even greater than a
thousand or more in number but then also
have the finesse to be able to look at
precisely the number of repeats and may
be present in a sample for the reasons
that I described the way we do that is
using a novel PCR reagent set based on
optimized chemistry primer design and
thermal cycling to be able to generate
products that can navigate this high GC
lineage content so just to get to give
you an overview the way we do this is we
have a three primer design we have two
outward gene specific primers one of
which is labeled with a floor core so we
can resolve it a platform downstream and
then we use a third primer which is a
repeat fund element so this is a primer
that it's complimentary to the CGG
repeat it lays down and binds to each
and every one of these repeat elements
and combines with a reverse primer to
create a multiplicity of products that
can be resolved so what this looks like
on a capillary electrophoresis for
fragment sizing is that you get two
categories of Peaks the series or repeat
prime Peaks on the left
a gene-specific peak on the right so
let's break this down so what it looks
like specifically is the combination to
outward gene specific primers will
generate a full-length peak that spans
the repeat and even if constrained by
the sizing of the platform is not
constrained by the PCR so we can make
very very long products here and then
the contrast of that is a complementary
signature it's generated from the
combination of each of these repeat
primed primers with the reverse primer
to create the series of different Peaks
that are separated by three nucleotides
or one repeat unit and this can
Telegraph a full mutation no matter how
long it may be because we've optimized
the primer concentrations to be able to
generate this with P prime pattern all
the way out to 200 repeats all the way
out to a full mutation and it gives you
the resolution to be able to look at
mosaicism then they exist within the
target in combination with gene-specific
Peaks so there's tremendous
complementarity here to make sure that
you never miss a full mutation but then
you also have sizing accuracy through
the gene specific Peaks and the
supporting repeat plan Peaks relative to
a calibrating bladder to be able to
convert mobility into CGG repeat number
so all the data I'm going to show you
from here on out is on the seeks to do
with one exception and I'll point that
out when I get there so let's take a
look at what the data look like off the
platform this is a challenging sample
that I'm showing you an electropherogram
for it's a pool of more than half a
dozen different alleles ranging from
normal with a low of 18 CG G's all the
way out to a whole mutation of well over
200 in fact in this sample it's over a
thousand CGG repeats and so the sample
tells us several things first of all it
tells us that we can accurately size
because the numbers that are labeled for
these Peaks are in fact the CGG numbers
that we know from orthogonal
methodologies that represent the
corresponding CGG numbers secondly it
covers a categorical range
augmentation and third we can even see
very closely sized repeats like 30 or 32
so separation of two CDG's we can pick
up I'll show you an example just a
minute of one so the platform's doing
what it should be doing we're able to
accommodate the breath of both sizing
for longer repeats as well as the
precision and accuracy for shorter
repeats now these are data that were
generated via a gene map or bide but
we've also shown proof of concept for
how these data can be ported unto our
Amplatz pcr CEF mr1 recorder software
and this is a fit for purpose software
that provides project management and
data management for fmr1 molecular
characterization it provides automated
sample QC and importantly push-button
genotyping so that you can nearly
instantaneously analyze hundreds of
sample genotypes and so our approach
particularly here in the US has been
with our you own products that
incorporate what we're hardware and
software what we're the right reagents
in this case for this challenging locus
for PCR that can be combined with the
right hardware and we've already
established this assay with thermo
Fisher's thirty seven thirty thirty-five
hundred and thirty one thirty
instruments and software in this case sa
specific software that gives you the
confidence of reliable readouts from a
primary electropherograms and creates a
system solution that's indian and so
we're excited to follow this then up
with some of the preliminary data that
we have from the seeks to do so whether
it's fragile x or some of these other
pathogenic repeat expansion disorders
like Brigitte's ataxia myotonic
dystrophy type 1 and 2 c 9 or 72 which
is affiliated with ALS and MTD all of
these disorders have in common
sequence variations from the primary
repeat expansion that can occur in the
repeat tract itself or in neighboring
sequence and so if fragile X that
sequence variation is AGG interruptions
and so these live within the repeat
tract and act as stability anchors for
expansion of the CGG repeat in the next
generation so they're important to
identify because they had another
dimension to the risk equation
associated with expansion from mother to
child so I gave you the example earlier
that if you have a repeat that's in the
mid-range of a premutation plus or minus
two CDG's can create a twenty percent
differential risk well if you take that
same mid-range premutation allele and
compared to a chi chi's versus zero a
Gigi's the two ages you sample will be
less than ten percent risk and zero AGG
sample will be more than 70 percent risk
so you can see as much as a tenfold
difference as a function of AGG for a
given CGG length so this acid doesn't
definitively reconcile the AGG in
sequence context an AGG number by itself
for that purpose we have a separate a
site that we run in a surgeon's clinical
laboratory known as expansion
interpreter but it does flag these AGG
interruptions and it provides another
data signature that can be very useful
in the characterization of ethanol on
wheels so how does this work so it's
still a repeat primed PCR approach the
same assay I described to you previously
the difference is that when those repeat
primers encounter an AGG element they
don't hybridize because the assays been
calibrated to prevent that so this
creates a footprint or a dip in the
signal intensity in the pattern that's a
telltale sign of an AGG interruption so
what it looks like this is a sample of a
2930 and again this is seeks to do data
you can see the two peaks here one of
these a 29 to 30 this is very different
than what you'd see for a 29 or for 30
homozygous seeks to do differentiates
those very nicely then we go into the
repeat prime pattern and there's those
primers kick in you start to generate a
series of the
would people on Peaks however once the
primer runs in to the AGG element it
doesn't generate product because it will
hybridize so now within that mobility
space you see a gap and that gap is
associated with the AGG then the assay
picks back up and you run out out
through that AGG you pick up the
corresponding CGG elements again and can
carry forward with the interpretation
there's actually another AGG here that I
didn't mark for simplicity purposes but
you get the idea the assay can give you
really subtle differences in signal
intensity that can be very informative
in a number of different ways and for
those to be fully tapped into you have
to have a high resolution platform like
this type of instrument so what I
mentioned previously was that the
ability to flag these large expansions
can accommodate the great deal of the
need for how you resolve molecular
characterization of fmr1 and in fact
using this primary amplitude XP crc e at
the mar 1 the edge inset you can reduce
the level of reflexing to say a southern
blot for the long expansions by 10 to 50
fold but you can't completely eliminate
it and that's because one other
important molecular characteristic of
expanded alleles needs to be adjudicated
and that is the methylation state so in
this particular case what we've done is
we've leveraged the long read PCR for
the amplitude technology to be able to
read out allele specific methylation and
we do that using a restriction in a
nucleus that's sensitive to methylation
marks so how this works is that we have
say a full mutation allele and it may be
methylated as many of them are and we
split that original sample into two Alec
lines we carry out a controlled
digestion and we carry out a digestion
with HEPA 2 which again will be a
sensitive to the methylation state if
the sample is methylated then at the two
sites
checked it and as a result you'll be
able to make a full-length amplicon
however if either of those two have the
two sites unmethylated then restriction
in the nucleus will cut and you will
break the template in a way that will
prevent a product from being formed and
so by dividing the sample into two
reactions and doing a control plus I
have a two digestion and then tagging
those two different reactions with two
different dyes on that reverse primer we
can create a composite signature that
gives us the sizing of each of the
alleles and a comparison of the fraction
of methylation for those alleles and so
I'm showing here is actually the same
profile for the composite of different
fmr1 alleles that was shown a few slides
ago from 18 all the way out to a greater
than 200 full mutation with the addition
of a couple of controls that are
incorporated within this reaction but
you start to see the benefit of being
able to assess methylation when you
split out the two color channels and
then being able to do relative
quantification of each of these Peaks to
assess the fraction that's not voided so
this is tapping into now three different
color channels within the seek studio
because we have a ladder a sizing ladder
in one channel and locks and then we
have these two other color channels that
we use to resolve a little specific
methylation the peaks that are circled
here in the control condition are those
that are completely obviated in the
methylation sensitive digestion so these
are unmethylated alleles and thus
they're digested way so you don't get a
corresponding peak in the green trays
those that are retained either in full
or in part are methylated to some degree
and the relative peak intensities of
these individual amplicons then allow us
to quantify what that methylation
fraction is I will point out this is a
new
we'll sample because the pull mutation
is unmethylated in this case we see
those rarely but we do see those it's a
function of the nature in this
particular sample but normally what we
would expect to see with the permutation
is that it's fully methylated but the
important point is that we can then
quantify that relative manipulation as a
function of each of the alleles now the
push may have looked a little bit
further one of the other things we did
was to look at the potential to be able
to resolve a multiple repeat expansion
targets in a single tube assay and a
single injection so in this case we've
looked at fmr1 and FM r 2 r 2 is a
putative transcriptional activator it's
a gene that sits very close to from r1
in the genome this is a pre mutation mm
mark 2 allele where a large expansion of
r2 like fmr1 are associated with
intellectual disability we tagged the
primers that are specific to these 2
different gene low-side with different
dyes so that we can resolve them just
like I described with methylation PCR
and in this case you can see the
premutation expansion that's associated
with that lamar to this sample that's in
the tube here from the single tube
multiplex is normal for my one so you
get the characteristic pattern you can
also see the AGG dips and that green
trace and so this shows that you can in
fact multiplex different repeat
expansion targets even when they do
represent and really difficult to
amplify GC character when we use the
right instrument so that's a high degree
of challenge working through fmr1 but
there's even a stiffer challenge and
that's with different pathogenic
expansion which is a jeep or c2
expansion in intron of c 9 or 72 so c 9
172 was identified by a couple of groups
in 2011 its genetic bridge that links
ALS in frontal temporal dementia it
repeat expansions at this locus are
associated with about 5 and 10% of
sporadic ALS and FTD and about 35 to 40
percent of familial disease
but the expansion's can be in the
thousands so this is really hard to
amplify so how do we do that well we've
taken the same approach that I described
before with the fmr1 target and fitted
it and optimized it for this particular
repeat expansion and what the profile
looks like very similar to what I showed
you with with fragile X is that this is
an expanded sample with a normal allele
is two repeats and the expanded allele
goes out beyond 145 if we do a zoom in
on that you can see the peak pileup
that's associated with that greater than
145 and it's important to note that much
like I had mentioned with fragile X that
the ability to amplify longer products
is within the PCR the limitation at 145
repeats in this case is only from the
platform it's not from the PCR and just
to give you an indication of that you
can see the Arturo's gel image here
which shows up to a thousand X a
nucleotide with beads that we can detect
now also like fragile X with the AGG
interruption there are sequence
variations that are associated with
cnn/orc 72 and I want to give you a one
example of that now this isn't an
interruption within the g4c to hex a
nucleotide repeat it's actually a little
bit outside of that region so these two
traces that you see the top one is a
1344 and you can see the corresponding
first with peak peak that's marked there
with a blue arrow the sample below it
that electropherogram represents 17
slash expanded sample but note that the
first repeat peak is now shifted over to
the left it's marked in red and if we
line up those two traces you can see
it's shifted by about four peaks a
little bit less than four peaks and
since the peaks themselves are distanced
by six nucleotides slightly less than
four peaks should represent slightly
less than 24 base pairs and since
they're shorter you would expect that
this may represent a deletion and in
fact that's exactly what we deserve when
we sequence this region by Sanger
sequencing we found that it's a 23 base
Elesha so the assay is the capability to
indicate these types of variations and
with the right platform you can you can
get a very good sense of any offset and
changes associated with insertions and
deletions which can be very powerful for
getting a lot of information from one
simple workflow so one other feature of
the seeks to do that one to highlight is
the fact that you can optimize the assay
for a sensitivity or resolution based on
your specific requirements using run
voltage so for example if we take an
expanded c9 or seventy two sample as
shown at the top here when we run it at
4,000 volts we can count out to about a
hundred seventy-five repeats a little
more than 145 because the baseline
conditions are a little bit different
than the ones I just showed you but if
we start cranking up the local to run
voltage to 6000 7000 8000 all the way to
9000 what you see is we begin to pull in
the number of repeats that we can count
from 175 all the way out to 120 however
we are increasing the sensitivity of the
asset because we're also drawing in the
pile of P and we're aggregating these
longer products into one peak that can
give you a much stronger signal so it
depends on what you're trying to
accomplish with your assay to be able to
favor individual high resolution sizing
out to some very long distance or
whether you want sensitivity beyond a
certain threshold the assay is a
capability to be able to do that and
because you can run many different
samples on one plate with different run
modules which is exactly what we did
here you have a tremendous amount of
flexibility to be able to quickly
isolate optimal conditions to suit the
assay at hand
so that's gc-rich what about the other
side what about a tier in sequence so
Tom forty is a gene that encodes a
mitochondrial membrane translocase that
has a intronic poly t homo polymer P and
this repeat has been linked with the
risk of age of onset and Alzheimer's
disease as well as the rate of cognitive
fine in elderly individuals in research
papers the poly T Lane has been
categorized in one of three different
length groups either short long or very
long and here again it's important to be
able to size accurately so not only do
we have to negotiate very 18 rich
sequence here very different story from
GC which we also have to be able to tell
the difference between 29 repeats and 30
repeats because they represent different
characters so a single repeat here is a
single nucleotide now if you use routine
PCR conditions to amplify this
particular region you get a profile that
looks like this but I have no idea but
this is one allele or it's two alleles
or it has mosaicism or it may be
happening here but again if we apply
ample Dex chemistry to this to be able
to provide very resolute and defined
products now we can tell exactly what
this is the two highest peaks are
infected two genotypes that are
associated with the two corresponding
alleles 30 40 30 60 separation of two
T's can be made very easily here this
data was generated on the 3,500 Cee
but we've also run it on the seek studio
and we get essentially the same result
we have this very characteristic peak
morphology for these samples that give
you single base pair resolution which is
exactly what we need at this locus and
this is a basis for a research product
that we launched fairly recently and can
help standardize this type of assessment
from one lab to the next to harmonize
results in accelerate progress so I'll
wrap up here with two prototype assays
one of these is at the dmpk locus which
is a gene that has a three prime CPG
expansion and that expansion is linked
to Maia time dystrophy type 1 so the
clinical threshold for mild disease is
about 50 repeats the samples shown here
is a census sample that was recorded in
a publication a couple years ago from a
lien study of a number of different
laboratories that was flagged as a 1275
we pick up the 1275 we also pick up a
mosaic at 63 that's repeatable who
believe that's real so it believes the
assays performing as expected it's very
sensitive what about a larger expansion
this one goes out though beyond 200
which would suggest more severe disease
by comparison this is a residual
clinical sample that was provided to us
from Ringwood genetic Center and you can
see the trace on the seek studio again
the ability to see the longer products
is within the PCR on just outside of the
reach and the platform in this case and
what that looks like is shown here in
the agarose gel out to an 1,100 CCGs
which we can very clearly differentiate
here so we have the capability to to
reach out for quite a bit of distance to
be able to size these alleles depending
on how we resolve them downstream and in
the last case is with Huntington's
disease this is at HTT it's in the exon
it's a CAG clinical threshold for
diseases around 40 repeats and I'm
showing an example here of a 1570 we
have no trouble picking up the seventy
effect we've run up to 50 with this
particular repeat expansion and been
able to detect it just fine so both of
these showed that the the seeks to do as
a potential would be able to accommodate
these number repeats so I'm gonna wrap
up here by saying that we have moved on
from the gy sera and arrays to look at
snips and understand associations to go
into other categories of sequence that
can be meaningful at the level of cell
function and disease and that includes
repetitive elements historically
repetitive DNA has been thought to be
you know typically neutral but now we
know that it's simply not the case we
know that these in many cases are
elements that are increasingly
discoverable knowable and have
diagnostic implications and using the
right tool for the right job
long read NGS a fantastic discovery tool
however if you want to operationalize a
workflow that can look at known repeats
and be able to provide definitive
information
for their molecular characterization the
combination of PCR using amp latech
chemistry's with capillary
electrophoresis the thirty seven thirty
to thirty five hundred and thirty one
thirty and now we see a lot of promise
around the seeks to do is a way to
address that particular need and so that
answers the three problems that I posed
at the beginning we do have reliable PCR
chemistry's that can amplify these
really challenging stretches of the
genome we do have small footprint
readily accessible and user-friendly
instrumentation that can resolve these
PCR products and we do have workloads
that can put these together to generate
real insight on the back end so I'll
stop there and open the floor for
questions
thank you so much dr. Latham for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window type
the question into the box that appear on
the screen and click send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's take a look at our
questions from our audience member we
have wonderful audience members today
our first question dr. Latham is what
was the size range of fragments that you
analyzed on the seek studio
okay sorry for the delay there so the
question was what was the size range of
fragments that were analyzed on the
seeks to do so we evaluated the
instrument with amplicons that could be
accurately sized from just over a
hundred base pairs to over a thousand
base pairs and I'll say that these
results were both appropriate for and a
consistent with the target
specifications for the various repeat
primed assays that I discussed without
the need for further analysis of the
products based on those specifications I
mean to be clear longer products I mean
even those that are up to several Kb
like that thousand ish g4c to repeat
xenon or 72 that I showed are detected
on the seeks to do but they pack into
the pilot peak and this actually has a
benefit the benefit is an improving
sensitivity which is ideal for say full
mutations of fmr1 or when you go beyond
200 repeats there's no indication of
genotype-phenotype correlations that are
useful
so this pileup that can happen can be
very beneficial for the assay because it
can increase that sensitivity now if
there is interest in sizing some of
these really long products then as I
mentioned you can potentially put them
on Tigers gel electrophoresis but for
the most critical step for all of the
assays that I discussed it would be to
achieve high resolution in hundred to
thousand base pair range and that's
exactly what the seeks to do delivered
in our evaluation
thank you so much dr. alida our next
question from our audience is what was
the detection sensitivity of low
abundance repeat containing amplicons
and what are the implications for the
detection of low level mosaicism in
genetic samples so in the course of our
evaluation we easily detected a 5% mass
fraction say with fmr1 in fact we
achieved as low as a 1% equivalent of
bone mutation as an admixture using a
940 CGG at the mall and so on in a
background of an expanded cell line
sample and we would expect that the
sensitivity for lesser repeats in a pre
mutation range would be similar we've
done comparable studies against some of
the other targets would be other genetic
analyzers in the ABI C family and have
seen results that are very consistent
with those types of findings so we
expect that being able to look at a few
percent of cell equivalents based on the
sensitivity of the instrument is
achievable
thank you so much dr. Latham and thank
you again for our live audience
participation we have some wonderful
questions coming in our next question is
you spoke of making a process around
these repeat detection assays can you
give a sense of how long a single
analysis takes or how many discrete
samples can be analyzed in a day from
raw samples to completed results that's
a good question and it really speaks
directly to the nature of the specific
assay and what the target locus and
specifications might need to be for the
given purpose so some of the targets
that I mentioned are relevant for
large-scale sample analyses and in those
cases you really would want to be able
to look at many samples at a time and
process those in a relatively you know
high throughput manner in terms of how
long it takes to be able to do an
analysis like that and then the assays
themselves are highly scalable so you
have the capability to run these at
larger densities and in terms of
workflow
you know most of these assays take less
than about an hour of hands-on time to
run through entirely because you do your
PCR you generate your products depending
on on the target and some of these
highly repetitive assays have relatively
short targets and might be again as I
mentioned only a 100 or a little bit
more in terms of base pairs in which
case you can do relatively short run
times to be able to resolve them and you
would need anywhere from one to a few
hours with a PCR depending on the target
so you could run through that entire
workflow within the scope of an a single
afternoon and then the analysis looking
at the the traces themselves can
you know typically in in about a minute
for trace or so depending on exactly
what you're looking for and that's kind
of the value of having a more ese
specific software solution where you can
automate that type of approach to be
able to generate a lot of useful data
relatively quickly so even if you have a
requirement to run hundreds of samples
at a time then the technology certainly
accommodates that and can be format into
those higher densities and with the
benefit of assay specific software down
stream that offers instantaneous
automated genotyping then you can
generate a tremendous amount of useful
information quickly to turn through
those number of samples at a time the
nice thing about the family of genetic
analyzers and now the seeks to do is
that pro labs that do have a need to
look at fewer samples at a time this
being a poor capillary system then it
accommodates that lower density very
very well but then also gives you that
flexibility to look at other types of
run conditions even even comparing types
of analyses on the same plate so you can
look at multiple small batches as well
as one set of samples with the same set
of conditions
thank you dr. Latham and what was the
sample input for the assays that you
described
so here again having a lot of
sensitivity to be able to attacked
low-level mosaic equivalents means that
you can pick up the primary alleles from
relatively small inputs we use typically
40 nano grams of genomic DNA is the
input into these assays we can certainly
use less and in fact part of our
evaluation was to do a titration series
we're able to go down to much lower
quantities and a range of even one
nanogram or so but our standard
conditions are in the forty nanogram
range and that's also to accommodate the
ability to look at some of the lower
level signals that may be present so you
can get a fully informed view of the
information from the sample to support
the clinical research questions you may
be interested in thank you so much and
thank you again for our audience
questions our next one is what run
parameters did you evaluate during
optimization of your assays on the seeks
to do so again I think this is an area
where the platform really shines because
the versatility it offers and how you
can nimbly manage different sample
conditions on the same plate in standard
way that one would approach the type of
optimization capillary electrophoresis
would be to vary the injection voltage
the injection time the run voltage the
run time and so we work with with all of
those variables to try to understand
what were the right set of conditions
for the given assay and it absolutely
depends on the assays some of the ones
that I showed data from today were run
for about 55 minutes as a run time some
of these were as short as 20 minutes
voltage conditions why I gave you the
example
changing the run voltage can favor
either sensitivity or resolution and
depending on what specifications were we
can turn that knob so we actually
evaluated a broad sweep of run voltages
from a V all the way up to 13 kV in in
one case and then we played around a
little bit with the injection voltage in
time as well so I think within those set
of variables you have a lot of a design
space to be able to come up with
preferred parameters for your given
assay and I'm just working within those
we found that that gave us a lot of
latitude for how we can make sure we're
getting the best possible results that
would allow us to accommodate the
different needs of each of these assays
thank you so much dr. Latham we have
time for one more question from our
audience member members and I just want
to remind everyone that any further
questions that are asked will be
directed back to you via email by a
thermo Fisher Scientific our sponsor for
today here's our last question dr.
Latham what was the workflow for the PCR
CES A's and time to result but the nice
thing about this approach is that unlike
NGS this is a very straightforward
methodology take care of purified
genomic DNA sample we've had experience
with lots of different sample types just
in general using this this assay
approach from buccal cells to whole
blood to urine to other sample types and
we can take that DNA you put it into the
PCR PCR can be anywhere from an hour to
a few hours depending on what the target
is and what the goals are you take that
product you can dilute it directly into
high die you don't need to clean it up
and then add in your ladder and inject
and then we run it on the instrument and
again in one of our cases with a Tom
forty assay we ran a shortest 20 minutes
so this means that our hands-on time is
minimal less than an hour for all of
these assays even looking at a larger
batch sizes it's very well accommodated
within that workflow and requires very
few steps and as a result we've had a
lot of experience with folks running
through these assays to get up and going
quickly with minimal training and be
able to run through either a small batch
size or a large set of samples even
within the span of an afternoon so I
think that that's the real benefit of
operationalizing the approach when you
know what the target is
thank you so much dr. Latham for your
presentation and for your important
research I also want to thank audience
members and lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcasts possible
for more information you can visit our
sponsor at thermo Fisher com
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through April 2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you so much
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye